thank you very much for the nice
invitation to speak to you today the
present day the computing power that we
have is vast it's enormous but even with
that there's continued need to make even
bigger and faster computers and this is
eginning to be a little bit of challenge
because the fundamental transistors that
you're building to make the computers
are kind of hitting physical limits and
Moore's law which has described the
exponential increase of computing power
over time is kind of slowing down and in
fact in recently the big gains in
computing high power has been achieved
by building big data centers and also
now looking at new architecture and if
you for example look at Google they've
in besides having CPUs in their data
centers they also have graphical
processing units and now they're making
special-purpose architecture and
hardware called tensor processing units
here's a picture of the latest third
generation TPU that Google is built to
solve machine learning power problems
and this has about a little bit greater
than about a hundred peda flops of
performance so this is at the
world-record supercomputer but of course
this is only for you know certain
problems in machine learning so the idea
of building special-purpose computers
and architectures to solve important
problems is is alive and well and lots
of things are happening and of course
there's great interests in Google and
elsewhere to see if we can do the same
thing for with kewpie use or quantum
processing units and can we harness
quantum mechanics to solve certain
problems way way faster than you can and
eventually do with any we do with a
classical computer and because of this
there's kind of an interesting time now
very exciting time it's kind of a
quantum space race where we have a bunch
of programs national programs trying to
go ahead and develop quantum technology
and build a quantum computer and in fact
there's a bill winding its way and I
think we'll be introduced soon to have a
big national program in United States
doing this and of course there are
certain companies involved one of them
being Google and again where it's great
we're all dry different things it's
progressing very rapidly it's very
exciting to see what's going on now I
don't you read about this in the press
there's a lot of talk about the number
of qubits and kind of this year there's
been a lot of talk about making 50
cubits and I'll talk about why that
number is here because of quantum
supremacy and it's great this is a new
frontier we have to do that but the main
point I want to get across today is it's
not just the number of qubits that
matters the quantity it's the quality of
the qubits that is incredibly important
and needs to be discussed at least in
scientific conferences and in fact in my
view quality is way more important than
quantity at this point we have to solve
the qualm the the quality problem and
you know that's just kind of a frontier
we have we have to be and I'm gonna
explain in detail what I mean by that
because I want you know potential users
of the quantum computer when you're
looking at seeing at what's going on in
the field for you and understand what's
really important now let's just do a
quick interview everyone know who knows
this quantum data is really interesting
because the information can be in a
superposition of states in some sense
making a parallel processor 0 or 1 at
the same time as you add more qubits the
hilbert space the state space doubles
every time you add a qubit which means
it's exponentially growing with the
number of qubits that's why we care so
much about the number of qubits and then
by the time you get to n equal 50 the
amount of parallel computation you're
doing to the 50 is taxing the size a
present-day supercomputer
and when you run the algorithms you're
taxing the time it takes to run these
algorithms so so that's why you know
this number is so interesting and of
course we can hopefully scale up beyond
50 the number 333 is actually very
important for me because to the 3/3 this
is a math people should know to the 333
is about 10 to the 100 or a Google
prospect obviously very important
milestone okay
but of course you only get an output
bits so you only can do this with
special algorithms that's fine
now this kind of discussion here is
great but you're talking about perfect
qubits that have no error okay that
doesn't exist at least yet I mean we
eventually think we can do that but
qubits are fundamentally have errors and
you have to deal with it so why how is
that happening well the way I like to
explain that is that when you take
classical information you can think of
it as a say a coin on a table and who
has coins in their pockets anymore so we
get out your cell phone so you can have
the cell phone up or the cell phone down
representing 0 and 1 and the important
thing to remember with classical
information that this information is
stable if it you have a little bit of
noise in the system it may lift up but
then there's a restoring force and
dissipation that makes these two states
stable at least for most the kind of
computers you would bill you know in a
quantum state that of course can be an
arbitrary superposition is 0 1 so it
could be 0 it can be 0 plus 1 or 1 and
actually kind of phasing it so you think
about it a coin
you know rotating freely rotating in
space and now when you have any amount
of noise to that coin it's going to
rotate a little bit and give you an
error and the point is is this kind of
continuous space that it lives in it's
an analog system so it's sensitive to
small errors and you fundamentally have
to deal with errors
whereas in classical it's digital it's
self-correcting and things got a lot
easier because of that ok now
when you have these single qubits you
can also put them together to do a
computation very much like in a
classical circuit where you have
information than they have through some
one bit not gates and tube you could and
gates and you can write a theorem that
with these kind of two logical
operations you can do any kind of
operation you want here's an example of
an adder in a quantum circuit one qubit
arbitrary rotation a two qubit see not
like an xor gate classical logic you can
then do an arbitrary calculation you
can't copy information but you can still
build your algorithms nevertheless so
here you have the individual qubits you
have the individual single qubit
rotations here the two qubit gates and
you build up together a circuit here and
you can do an arbitrary computation
provided you initialize it and measure
it here this is kind of laid out in
space here it's laid out in time kind of
like how you would think a normal CPU
program but the analogy is very good now
the problem of course is I told you that
these had errors in it so by the time
you make a complicated calculation
you're gonna probably have some errors
coming out here that's gonna mess up
your final state and what you do of
course is you use quantum error
correction which basically encodes the
qubits one logical qubit state into many
physical qubit States you can't measure
if the qubits of change or else you'll
change the state but you do some kind of
parity measurements to figure out that
there were bit flips and then with
enough parity measurements you can
figure out which one did so basically
you have this error correction circuit
where you're doing parity measurements
over and over again and then you do some
classical error decoding and logic to to
change the fix error correction and also
do logic on it this is actually similar
to classical systems where you use a
clock and a D flip-flop and doing logic
to kind of synchronously do the
calculation here here the
synchronization goes with the error
correction the important point here is
look we want to build a quantum computer
with about 10 to minus 9 errors
antenna maestro because that's how many
operations we have in our circuit okay
so you want some exponentially small
errors okay that's not where we are
experimentally that's where we're gonna
go and to do that with say the surface
code you need about a thousand cubits
and 0.1% error so this is nice see this
but part error and pardon a thousand is
way this is kind of reasonable maybe we
can do that it's it's not anywhere near
this but that's something we think we
can do and of course the downside here
is we have to build a lot of qubits to
do that well you know this has billions
of transistors or trillions of
transistors in it you know maybe we can
eventually figure that out so that's
that's the difficulty in the fan so note
here that we have quantity and quality
in order to go ahead and do error
correction so what I think you know as
you people are talking about the
progress in making a quantum computer
this is not just your building a system
so it's not a one-dimensional horse race
in the press that's the number of qubits
it's both the qubits quantity and the
quality in the same device and of course
there's lots of other things you have to
worry about but these are the main ones
at least for right now so if you want to
talk about where we are right now and
what we need to do you talk about the
quantity number of qubits you talk about
the quality and this for example is the
worst qubit operation as opposed to the
best thing that Cubans do which is
typically what physics you want to talk
about
it's always an engineered system it's
the worst that matters okay so it's a
limiting error rate so I was telling you
for 10 to minus 9 errors you need about
10 to minus 3 error per operation you
need about a thousand cubits for one
logical qubit and then if you have
higher error rate than the number of
qubits you need for logical qubit goes
up and if you have a lower error rate
then the number goes down it's kind of
on this curve here now the important
thing to of course note is that as the
error rate goes up this starts to
diverge
in fact blows up at the error correction
threshold at about 1% so that's kind of
1% characteristical we have to do of
course we have to do better because we
don't want to build an infinite number
of qubits maybe mathematically that
wouldn't bother you here at here at this
Institute but in building something you
know we have to they have to make this a
finite number and I'll call here above
10 to minus 2 I'll call this the Death
Zone where if we had an infinite number
of qubits we couldn't do error
correction right you have to you have to
be so good and then doing that ok so and
then and so this is kind of where we
have to do I I call on this scale the
error correction gain it's kind of like
transistor gain you know if you build a
new transistor technology and your
transistors you just think you've been
scaled to billions of those transistors
but the transistors have no gain it's
gonna be useless right the transistors
have to have some gain to build a real
circuit so I'm calling this error
correction gain or the gain has to be
greater than 1 maybe typically around 10
that's not unusual for transistor
technology maybe 10 to 100 is what you
typically want to do and that's kind of
similar here we're doing the error
correction okay so that kind of tells
you yes I'm just saying that that you by
adding more qubits your logical system
gets better so you have some information
gain it's qualitative
where is this this graph is coming from
when you work out the error correction
theory of what you need to do for 10 to
-9 errors you know you work it out if
you have lower you have a worse error
rate you need more cubits and it's the
trade-off you can solve by you know
looking at the error correction theory
that's a single logical qubit that's all
we're talking about here yes this is for
the surface code which kind of has the
best bounds but you know you could do it
for all the codes this is the easiest
case we know of okay now given this and
given the fact that you when you read
press reports about quantum computers
and they talk about quantity you know
how many qubits are making whatever you
would kind of think well yeah you know
they have some gain they're below the
threshold and then you know once you're
below the threshold quantity matters I
mean obviously the better the error the
fewer quantity we need but then it's
kind of like as long as you have some
this error gain it doesn't matter okay
but this is what's really odd that's not
the case at all
the case is is that the typical qubit
error rates that people are talking
about our error rates around 5%
something little bit more some a little
bit less you're up here in the Death
Zone
so if you're just talking about quantity
at this point it's kind of like hype
okay it's not where we want to be we
want to be down here okay and you can I
say you can it's great you know we're
getting to 50 a hundred qubits whatever
this is all great but if you don't have
the quality well you know yeah are we
going to be able to do this kind of
thing so what we're doing at Google is
our strategy is to really focus first on
how to get the error rate down and then
to move across here because it's well
known that you know in management
circles that you want to solve your
hardest problem first okay and get
everyone thinking about that so what
happened is
says nine two bits a little bit under 10
to minus ooh this is what we did at UC
Santa Barbara and because we were kind
of dipping our toll underneath this
threshold line this is kind of why we
decided to move to Google and build this
thing and what we're going to do today
is talk a little bit about the quantum
supremacy experiment at point one here
at about 5070 two qubits a little bit
lower error rate to show quantum
supremacy I'll explain that then number
two with that you can't classically
simulate that anymore
maybe we can find some near-term
applications that'll be useful it's not
known whether we can do but certainly we
can look for that and then around point
three here at a thousand cubits in 10 to
minus three error we can do logical we
can do error correction and least make
one really good qubit a 10 to minus 9
error which is what you need and then of
course you want its need to scale that
up something to like a million cubits
million physical qubits a thousand
logical qubits to do a full quantum
error correction so this is kind of the
trajectory that we we need to need to
get to so you know that that's the
that's the goal and and you know we have
to make our qubits better as well as
making more of them yes those are the
hardest things to make
that was in the past decade so some
important ideas in engineering in
physics that completely change the
picture for one qubit gates and qubit
longevity so my question is would you
expect some change and it's great that
people are looking at those ideas there
are things that people are doing that
are improving upon what we've done in
the past it's kind of our thing there
are other people like topological qubits
who are trying to fundamentally address
the question and all these ideas are
good the main point I want to make here
is you know it's not so look it's great
to do to write a nature or science
article to have a new gate but when it's
only 70% fidelity which is enough to get
you in nature in science it's great but
it's not taking you down here where you
want to go you want to do the metrology
you wanted to develop not just a new
gate but a good gate and a damn good
gate in order to you know address the
field and the hard part is you can't
just do that on one or two qubits you
have to do it on lots of qubits because
making it on lots of qubits pushes
against making good qubits and you have
to do everything at the same time really
well this is hard so I just want to
point out this is really hard I'm not
sure everyone's talking about it in this
serious way that we have to solve this
problem if we're gonna build a quantum
computer
we can't just hope it's gonna happen you
have to work hard on it well I want to
give just some examples of what's going
on this is in what kind of the published
or at least in public literature between
the Google this is you know four years
ago of five cubits of ice okay this is
old recent IBM and and Righetti and what
happens is when they build these big
systems they can measure the individual
tube Ubud gate fidelities
and what I do here is you can histogram
them but that's an integrated histogram
where each of these steps represents
another a gate that they made here and
this this is nice because you can see
what's going on for a small number of
gates and kind of see what the
probability distribution is like see see
for the Google five we had five qubit
gates around 0.5 to about one percent
error
the IBM gate that goes down to ten to
minus two but all goes all the way up to
about 10 percent errors and here's
Righetti starting at about seven percent
and going up to about 20 percent these
are these are the two qubit a gate
errors and each one of these steps is
another two qubit gate with their errors
so you have a distribution of to give a
gates from 1 percent to 10 percent
qubits on them so there are 20 cubits
and so the best to Kupa gate of the 20
cubits that you have has error rates
down there the point I want to make is
when you listen to physicists and you
see tables in review articles they tell
tend to tell you the best one I mean we
know we do that other people do that
it's just fine okay we want to know
what's best but the reality is when you
build a complicated system things get
hard and you actually see a distribution
and the distribution here is maybe a
factor of two so that's not so bad but
here the distributions are factors of
ten okay it's that you know between your
average and your worse is a factor of
five okay and okay we're working on it
they'll get better and we'll understand
what's going on I just want to say it so
this is a lot easier I'm clearly clearly
yeah well you know there's the data so
that's fair that's fair it's hard I want
to say it's hard okay and that you have
to talk about the average fidelity as
well as the
just okay and remember that's on top of
the fact that you have to not just show
one or two buckets you have to do many
qubits right so this is all this is hard
and all I'm really trying to say here is
look where this is the Death Zone okay
we need to get down here all of us need
to make it better okay but you know some
a little bit of course they you have to
get the average and some more oh by the
way when we made our 9 2 bit device
the average fidelity is compatible with
this so it's not so crappy when you
scale up a little bit so that's good
yeah I'll show you the data so you know
we have to get better so for here we
have two we know that about a factor or
two here or so is our control and
another factor or two or so is that we
have to make the coherence of the qubits
and some other things that are going on
there but the real difficulty actually
is moving this is making all of the
qubits work well and understanding all
the physics and getting rid of all the
dirt physics yes so what you do to
measure these gate Fidelity's is you
take the two qubits and you make the two
qubit gate and you do that in a bunch of
times
putting known but random single qubit
gates in between something called gran
demise gate benchmarking and then by
looking at the random States and looking
at the decay of the of the final state
you can get an error per gate yeah so
these tend to be experiments only on two
of the five or 20 or 19 or whatever and
you're gonna say well what happens when
you run it on a complicated experiment
you know with many qubits can you still
get that gate fidelity so even though
we're doing here this is kind of the
best-case scenario you want to know what
happens we
running on a complex things and I'll
show you how to do that if I have enough
time I'd like to have enough time but
I'll show you how to do that that's what
the quantum supremacy experiment allows
you to do which is important of course
you want to get you've indeed this needs
to be good and then you have to be able
to control your whole system all at once
yeah you know you could you could talk
about those kind of echoes kind of
differences and you know everyone is
gonna say that their architecture is the
best and whatever and that's fine but
you can you can do that I'm going to say
that if our qubits were kind of didn't
have some peculiar physical problems
with them these would probably all be
good but I'm saying I I'm my opinion is
that what makes one architecture Beavan
the other has to do with some subtle
errors that are in the qubits that you
have to work around which is products so
you can do that if you want and then
these are called simultaneous benchmark
and you want to show that if you really
turned the other ones off or maybe not
so off you're getting the same thing so
there's a bunch of things you can do
like that generally if you if you
separate them properly you don't have a
degradation of this quantity but of
course what's harder is if you start
interacting them do they gives you the
errors add in a simple-minded way and
I'll show you an experiment that you
know hopefully that'll get to get to
that okay given you're asking a bunch of
questions I'll go over the hardware what
this is is an integrated circuit super
that
[ __ ] this is all ground playing these
are cuts in it this cross here forms a
capacitance between the cross and ground
the Josephson junctions at the bottom
are basically nonlinear inductors where
you can vary the inductor by putting
current into here and flux into here and
this makes a nonlinear LC resonator that
forms the qubits essentially a six
gigahertz microwave oscillator very high
quality factor very low dissipation and
nonlinear so that the zero one
transition is a different frequency than
one two and then you can stay in the
qubit space okay here's a picture of the
nine qubits that I'll give Jada on
instead of the X's these are eyes so we
have our two control lines one controls
the frequency and phase the other the
amplitude of it with a microwave pulse
we connect to this line here to read it
out and then these are actually coupled
together you can couple together simply
with capacitors but we do that with some
variable mutual inductance so we can
have a swap operation where a photon
swaps between two gates which is
controlled by the line here it's either
turn the coupling has turned to zero or
turned positive or turn negative
depending on how much current we we flow
into here and then we have nine cubits
here okay so we're gonna do nine qubit
experiment now let me tell you something
here that's not so obvious we calibrate
this and we get everything to work what
we'll do is we'll calibrate what happens
when this photon swaps from here to here
by of this gate so we calibrate the gate
so we calibrate this one separately this
one's off and then we calibrate this one
and then we calibrate those some
separately when we run the algorithm
we're gonna turn all of these on at the
same time which we didnt calibrate for
is it gonna work and this is kind of the
problem you can have good two qubit
gates but what's gonna happen when you
turn everything on at the same time is
it still gonna work as your calibration
gonna work and you know it's not clear
you have to do experiments to show that
you know how to do that and we'll show
that indeed if you model everything
right so you know what's going on
we can essentially get the same behavior
when everything's turned on everything's
working at once is we got with the
individual gates that's not obvious you
have to show that that's what's that's
hard so here's the latest qubit chip
these are 11 qubits here 11 qubits here
22 qubit chip this is their qubit chip
made with special processing we flip
chip this there's a little indium
spheres that connects here to here so
the two chips gets together this is the
wiring we put inside a printed circuit
board wire bond to it bring those wires
out to a line and then we control them
that goes into a dilution this package
here this goes in with a bunch of cables
going down to the device this package is
in a dilution refrigerator at about 10
millikelvin so this is so that the
thermal energy KT
is much much less than the quantum
energy which is about the third of a
Kelvin or so so it's a big factor
between those two and thus you can get
rid of all the thermal effects and then
all these wires are taken up to the top
of the cryostat here's a picture looking
at the top of the cryostat right here
with all the wires coming out and those
wires go to this breakout panel and then
we wire that to these crate of
electronics here which controls
everything so this is it took this
picture or yesterday this shows about
you know 200 a little bit more than 200
wires connected to our qubit and then
connect it to electronics and then we
just we just control it then and use the
biceps and then you know here it is is a
dilution refrigerator control
electronics and we sit behind our
computer all day you know measuring the
qubit and get trying to get it to work
okay so let's talk about the quantum
supremacy experiment you measure that
two qubit gates are working at a certain
level well what happens when we build
the whole system is it still gonna work
okay and the way we're gonna test that
is something we call the Quan
supremacy experiment with about a 50
cubit the system okay we're gonna run a
simple algorithm on that 50 cubed system
and get the outputs and then to check if
those outputs are correct we're going to
compare them against the simulation from
a classical supercomputer given that 50
cubits is is so many you have to use a
supercomputer to do that so it's
basically this little physics experiment
taking data with that versus this big
classical supercomputer so it's
interesting why do we want to do this
some of our like competitors have been
saying all this is just a Google
marketing ploy you know of doing
squattin supremacy and I'm gonna say you
know that's actually kind of right in
the sense in the sense that you know
computer scientists had been hearing
about quantum computing for a long time
and hearing about the potential for a
powerful quantum computer but all they
hear about is like two qubit
spooky entanglement experiments winner
thing and actually showed something
powerful so what we're trying to do in
this to the computer scientists is show
that you can build something that
computes something that's powerful in
the sense that it has to be checked with
a quantum computer so okay at least
Google executives understand this and
that's all really I care about in terms
of the science the whole point is the
quantum computation is computing on this
gigantic hilbert space what evidence do
we have that theory actually allows us
to do this and we expected the case and
if it doesn't work we're gonna explain
it blame the experimentalist but you
know in classic physics style you want
to say well how big of a system can you
make and you know so that you know that
superposition is still working okay and
finally in terms of the engineering
point when you build a quote when you
build any computer you have to do some
tests to see if it's working so
typically what you do with a computer
computer and your operating system
whatever you do a hello world experiment
where you just have to do the simplest
thing you can think of to show that you
know what you're doing and this is kind
of the simplest algorithm you can think
of that does a full test and you check
whether your whole operating system
especially your hardware is working so
again the computer scientists like this
so this is kind of a computer science
centric experiment so it's just you run
an algorithm where you take the qubits
single qubit gates two qubit gates do it
over and over again and the see the two
qubit gates are controlled ZC nots
that's known and then the single qubit
gates are randomly chosen from known
gates which are Clifford operations 90
or 180 degree operations on the rotation
or some non Clifford operations so it's
a randomly chosen but known operation
you then with that run the quantum
computer and measure a bunch of time
let's say a hundred thousand times and
given the randomness nature of it you're
kind of expecting all the possible to
the end possible outcomes okay and then
and you would say Brant you know you'd
randomly guess any outcome as a
probability one over to the N however
you calculate what this is supposed to
do just integrating the Schrodinger
equation or other ways of doing it so
that you get the probability to get this
now what's interesting is when you
actually look at this quantum system you
don't get a uniform random distribution
the distribution of states is actually
very similar to what you see in laser
speckle which I'm showing here with a
laser going through a ground glass that
diffuses the light but you see in
certain directions the light is bright
and in certain directions the light is
dim because it's not a uniform
distribution the statistics the
coherence of the light makes some
directions more intense and some less
intense and similarly the probabilities
are measuring all this states there are
some states that are more
bill in some states or less probability
and the way you you checked that of
course you're going to measure the most
probability ones the way you check that
by a sampling here is that for a
particular state that you measure you
look it up and hear what the probability
should be and since that probability is
higher than the average if things are
working right that's going to be bigger
than P classical and this is going to be
bigger than one in fact when you do it
properly the difference between a random
choice and the full quantum speckle
choices is one and then you can tell the
difference whether the key thing is
working and what's interesting is is if
you have one error like a bit FIP or
face slip or you programmed it wrong or
something you get to the classical so
it's a very sensitive test of whether
everything in your quantum computer is
working properly which is of course what
you want to know you just say if you
have no information because it's this
random complicated circuit you're gonna
the only class only guess you could have
is that it's going to be uniform
distribution and that's what happens
classically so if I take classical light
white light shine it through the ground
glass is gonna look uniform I take
coherent light it's gonna have this
speckle pattern and same thing here
though coherent States have the speckle
patter I can talk about that later I
just don't have time to go into it
that's just what happens so the ideas
you can get about a hundred thousand
samples in about a second that's what
the quantum computer does and to
calculate this it might take days I mean
you have to measure a hundred thousand
samples and this is so much bigger than
this that you know the quantum computer
looks powerful much more powerful and of
course this is all growing exponentially
with system size
okay so that's that's the basic idea in
the experiment so the depth is actually
important so the comp the computational
complexity gets hard at about 45 48
cubits and the depth here should be
around 40 43 something like that
so you know that's to be deep as well as
wide this is you have to go through
those details but yes do you have to do
both of those yeah over a thousand gates
and and thus you need about ten minus
three error hey you could do a little
bit worse than that turns out they were
five times ten to minus three so we have
to improve that a little bit and then
you know you can have on average a
couple errors and still see a signal so
yeah there are some things you can play
with there's an exponential decay you
have to go through the statistics of it
carefully but we can talk about it okay
okay so this does this idea even work
can you test the system so like we took
that nine qubit device and ran a
slightly different but similar in
concept so quantum supremacy experiment
where this is for the example for five
cubits and we ran that and we measured
all the two-photon States coming out of
here okay
so we run through that and then in blue
we see the probabilities after measuring
this a bunch of times and you see that
there's lots of small ones and a few big
ones this probability distribution
coming out of this looks like speckle
looks like qubit speckle lots of small
to you big we changed the instance the
programming that we did to it and you're
gonna get another speckle pattern okay
which is different than this again lots
of small few big ones your instant three
here instance four okay and basically
I'm gonna say that the speckle pattern
okay so you see a speckle pattern and
you can look at the statistics of that
you you know that your corner
Computers coherent because you have saw
a speckle pattern okay so just from the
raw did probabilities you can tell that
of course what you really want to know
is what's the speckle pattern what you
predicted okay so by calibrating the
system very carefully and this is about
a year of work this is a lot of work
okay and calibrate in doing everything
right you can get model predictions for
what we programmed in and those are in
the red dots and you see where the blue
is low the red is low and where the blue
is high the red is high and then when
you change to another instance you see
the same thing that it matches here it
matches here and matches here which
tells us that when we control our system
we really know what the Hamiltonian is
we know what's going on with our quantum
computer it isn't calibrated it's
verified the work properly because the
speckle pattern matches the theory so
this is only five cubits and I think
only like five depth so it's it's not
you know not very many operations okay
so in fact is it too good to be true do
you expect that this is the experiment
you do for between three cubits and nine
cubits you run this this algorithm okay
and then you do the depth of it which is
the number of cycles okay and you expect
the higher the depth or the more number
of qubits the the worse the the fidelity
is going to be in exactly that's what we
see we see all these are slope and down
for more cycles we see when we go from
three to nine the fidelity goes down and
you can work out what the error is per
cycle and basically all this data
collapses into the idea that you see
about 0.3 percent error per gate and per
cycle okay so and and and this is
consistent with what we expect for the
basic gate fidelity's when you run a
complicated system it works properly you
might say well why is it 0.3% of
not point five percent the particular
algorithm we ran who was a photon number
conserving so we threw out a small you
know like less than half of the data
where that didn't happen thus you're not
seeing energy decay things so it's gonna
be a little bit better and in a way that
we make sense to us so this number makes
sense that's basically a cycle would be
would be this it's a slightly different
algorithm where we put in an over two
photons and then we just do swap gates
as the entangling operation so we
conserve photon numbers it's a little
bit different algorithm it's the number
it's yes
so I guess thank you so I call a photon
a qubit one state okay so it's an
excitation so if we have nine and nine
cubits these are nonlinear slightly
nonlinear qubits so these are almost
harmonic oscillator states so that's the
jargon we use I agree it's not so good
these excitations
it's just jargon sorry it when you study
electronics you have to learn a lot of
jargon so sorry we use that okay you're
computing about five hundred states in
parallel here okay that's the Hilbert
space
just to show we can do other things with
it we're gonna take this 9 cubit device
and map the problem of quantum materials
problem basically a two-dimensional
sheet of atoms with an applied magnetic
field let's say a nine by nine array
maps into nine qubits using the correct
gauge and then you look at the
excitation energy of that system versus
applied magnetic field where one
corresponds to one flux quantum into an
atom cell which physically would be
about ten thousand Tesla so this is a
huge thing so you can't do this in the
lab you can of course approximate that
with some different experiments you can
of course compute that the interesting
thing about this problem is when you
predict that for this particular system
you see this very complicated diagram it
could similar to the hofstadter
butterfly when they first computed this
you see kind of a gap here you see lots
of structure in this so when we run our
quantum computer and map it to this
problem we know it's working really well
but are we going to be able to see this
kind of structure to it so you just
calibrate the system you check it and
then you run it just like you would you
use a regular computer and when you do
that you get the dots as your
experimental data which you see you know
agrees very well with all the structure
that we're seeing here we see all the
all the nice little bumps and Wiggles
here in fact the difference between
experiment in theory is a few megahertz
on hundreds of megahertz scale so you
know it does a good computation I'm
saying that you'd probably we've done
other experiments look for correlations
of the of the excitations and and the
like you know you can you can get a lot
of physically meaningful information out
of it so this shows that you can you can
get what I would say is physically
useful information out of a quantum
simulation that matches what you expect
of course it's still kind of a toy
problem it's only nine cubits so
hopefully we can match something on a
real problem to something that we can do
on quantum supremacy and then measure
something you know that would be very
hard to do computationally but you know
that's that's what what we're hoping to
do in the future yes yeah okay so what
we have right now is we built a
Bristlecone chip and what we have are
these these trans Mon X's arranged in a
square grid and we put in this extra
space here we put in our resonators to
read all of them out 2d grid nearest
neighbors and you seventy-two qubits
here's the chip with all the lines
coming out on the outside and this is in
the refrigerator and getting tested
right now and you know things look
interesting but there's nothing to
report we have to get all this
calibrated and figure it out really well
okay so I just want to summarize here
when the main message here is you needed
both quantity and quality of the qubits
okay quantity is pretty easy to measure
quality you need to know what your
limiting error is which is generally the
two qubit gates that's the hardest thing
not just the best but you want to know
average when you build a big system okay
and of course this quality has to be
measured a quantity and also although
you're measuring the basic errors you
want to know what the system errors are
- okay and I've showed how quantum
supremacy can do that
yeah and that's like I said that's
because in our business isn't brackets
that's because we've subtracted away our
energy decay terms with the particular
post-selection we did but I'm gonna say
that if you weren't to do that your
system errors would be about 0.5 0.6
percent similar this it's a different
device and different management but it's
compatible these are very compatible I'm
just saying that yeah the system errors
here would be good we have some other
measurements that say that these system
errors here are compatible with the 0.5
0.7 percent it's really compatible with
that but you want to do those
experiments okay those are the big
things of course there's more as huge
number of things you have to worry about
building the system I want to point out
speed as important as you're looking at
it there can be a huge difference in the
speed between different technologies
maybe up to a million and you know okay
it depends what you're doing as it
matters but just be aware of that and
also the things like connectivity
matters - okay you error-correction you
need at least a 2 d clearly more
connections gives you more things to do
so that's something you have to worry
about but it's it's do so
here's are the numbers I talked in this
thing I went from 1 D to 2 D in
Bristlecone we have 72 qubits and we
have to see how this is III think we're
gonna be able to get number similar to
this but getting everything to work at
the same time is hard and you know we
just have to do the careful measurements
before I talk about it so we're
optimistic but you know we have to do it
and that's just this takes time ok thank
you very much
[Applause]
could you say more about how you measure
the system so the system error is is
basically by doing the quantum supremacy
experiment and getting those those
comparing what we expect theoretically
experiment experimentally do the quantum
supremacy experiment we can back out the
total fidelity of the whole operation
and then we back divide out all the
number of say two qubit operations to
get the basic that two qubit oh yeah no
gate error yeah and and that's actually
still probably something people will
debate whether that's happening for real
and we have to test that but that's kind
of what we see so far within a factor
two if you design the algorithms right
you you can you can add you can add the
errors probabilistic you know that
classically that's kind of a strange
assumption it's not a necessary what I
would say is you do things when you
build your algorithm to to change the
state in a way that you can compute but
the kind of randomized whatever errors
you're having so that this kind of thing
happens and that means you're compiling
it properly and that's why it works but
this is a big deal
all right the next feature has been my
party WSDL about testing since it's the
small